I think the way our student loans are
given is super predatory on people who
are young and don't understand or people
who think that their education is going
to translate into a higher paying job
and they don't really think about the
consequences when I was deciding which
college to go to the process was very
heavily dependent on where I'd get the
most money from but I also really wanted
to go to a school that would challenge
me and a school that I felt like I could
thrive in for undergrad I took about
eighteen thousand dollars in total I was
for grad school oh gosh um I initially
had a full ride the first year and then
the second year came I talked to
financial aid and they were like
surprised you only had a full ride for
your first semester and so I ended up
taking about a hundred K extra in
student loans that should have never
been taken out I went to law school and
I studied abroad so I have a little bit
of loans from that but school was
actually less expensive a huge portion
of my loans are from one year of grad
school I did when I moved back to the
states I originally had about seventy
seventy-five thousand dollars in loans
from that one year of grad school it's
now up to almost a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars when I was debating
taking out loans it wasn't really a
question the federal government allows
first year undergrad students who are
dependent to take out about five
thousand five hundred dollars worth of
loans although I knew it was a huge
financial commitment to take on
especially at such an early stage in my
academic career I decided to take that
out just because I thought it was worth
coming out here for as soon as we opened
up my student loans I was delinquent and
I think my first payment due was like
$1500 which I don't think I even made in
a month there's not a lot of information
that's given out I know there was
entrance and exiting counseling sessions
but it doesn't really tell you what to
do
I was jumping from job to job just
trying to keep a roof over my head and I
got super lucky one day because I was
pounding the pavement looking for jobs
the job turned out to be processing
student loans
and since then I figured out how to keep
my loans and repayment but I'm actually
currently paying zero because I don't
even make enough to be paying monthly
rates straight out of school the economy
was horrible and I was struggling and
realized it just wasn't even what I
wanted to do now I do something
completely different where I don't earn
a ton of money I'm on income based
repayment so I make really small
payments they call it negative
amortization where I'm now accruing
interest on the interest in my mind I
was thinking well I'm gonna be a lawyer
and I'm gonna make tons of money I know
it's gonna take me some time but I'm
gonna pay off these loans taking out
loans is very normal nowadays and it's
kind of expected for most students when
they go off to college I started paying
$100 per month and I'm hoping to pay off
my loans within five years after I
graduate I thought taking out loans was
worth it in the end just because I was
able to attend my dream school and I'm
currently attending my dream school one
of my co-workers was just very eager to
get her hands on my loans and it turns
out that we could have avoided my
interest rates going up so now within
the span of about four or five years it
went from like a hundred and seventeen K
and now it's engine 45 K I believe the
last time I checked so it is
nerve-racking
but I'm hoping that within ten years
I'll figure out how to get it all
forgiven I really didn't understand the
magnitude of what taking out that money
would mean particularly the terms of the
loan cuz a huge amount of it is
something called grad plus so some of
the loans are federal subsidized which
means the interest is lower and I
believe I'm not even sure that it's
simple interest so I just pay the
interest off the principal whereas grad
plus they let you take out so much money
and they charge you a higher interest
rate and the interest compounds
compounds compounds and I'm paying
interest on the interest and I'm not
even paying all of the interest in each
payment everyone should get educated on
loans before taking them out I know I
wasn't very educated on loans and I
still am a little confused on what
exactly they mean the only loan
education I think that I received was
after I already took some out
I think definitely people should be
educated before that
[Music]
there are some forbes articles now that
thankfully detail it well but even when
I was working as a student loan
processor we had to scour the website
and there was like little hidden tips
and tricks even now that I am pretty
comfortable with how my student loans
are looking I still feel that I
constantly have to scour the news for
any new legislation that might pop up
even though I had internships and a lot
of experience in my field of law it was
really hard to find jobs it was really
frustrating I had no idea what I was
doing and it was really hard to get paid
what I was worth ultimately I realized
that isn't what I wanted to do but my
expectation was I'm gonna finish school
and I'm gonna get a job and I'm gonna
make money and I'm gonna be able to pay
my loans and live a good life and that
was not my experience at all
colleges and the government itself have
the responsibility to somehow decrease
the cost because if college just keeps
getting more and more expensive I
already know people who don't think it's
worth paying I mean not going to college
is perfectly fine but then we'll see
also a decrease in people attending
higher education just because they can't
afford it anymore knowing what my
background was like I have come a long
ways but at the same time I just really
want to be financially stable because
it's affected the quality of my life it
made me realize everything kind of runs
on what you have what you don't have and
it dictates where you fall on the ladder
of mobility having all that debt from
all those years of struggle is still a
weight on me even though I feel like now
I've finally found my path going to
school does not guarantee you a job and
I think at a certain point in time going
to school and getting good grades would
have guaranteed you some kind of job and
that's just not the case anymore
ultimately when it comes to going to
your dream school and paying loans
versus maybe going to another school you
wouldn't be as happy at you have to
think of whether or not it's worth it
honestly if I knew that I would have to
have all those loans under my belt I
would have gone and applied to the Ivy
League school of my dreams I would have
applied to Harvard I wish somebody had
told me you should never allow the
logistics of something to keep you from
achieving what really matters to you the
fact that I already borrowed money I
just wish I could have put it to better
use I think for someone let's say coming
out of high school or even college I
would say take some time to work and be
in the real world and build those life
skills let's be honest I don't think any
17 or 18 year old coming out of high
school really knows what they want to do
and even if they do hey life throws you
all sorts of wrenches so chances are
you're not going to do what you think
you're gonna do at 18 real life skills
that is the valuable experience that is
going to serve you in your life in the
long run
[Music]
you